Julian Assange is facing a 175-year
prison sentence he published over 700
000 classified documents that Army Intel
analyst Chelsea Manning gave him the U.S
government no like he wait don't
journalists do this all of the time yes
they do what would a conviction of
Julian Assange mean for free speech and
journalism let's just look at the
charges really quickly they fall into
three buckets hacking aiding and
Publishing the hacking charge is Small
Potatoes it's like five year sentence
Max for allegedly working with Manning
to try to crack a government computer's
password that's the first charge this is
where it gets serious because mannion
was a convicted spy for stealing all of
these government secrets and Assange
published them he's now being charged as
a spy too for helping her which is a big
effing deal and this leads to the third
bucket and the scariest to me as a
journalist the U.S says that Assange
violated the Espionage Act by taking
documents containing the names of
military informants and Publishing them
on the Internet the crime is literally
for publishing I need a whole separate
video to explain all this it's up now go
to the other